okay I think new Doctor Who stuff is
done breaking what did I miss
[Music]
so yeah there's some stuff that's gone
on over the last couple of weeks related
to Marvel that um I haven't had a chance
to talk about because I've been I've
been buried in Doctor Who stuff but um
this kind of gives me a chance to do an
overview and sort of maybe catch up
anybody else who has not been following
everything part of what will be
interesting about this is I'm not sure
too many of these as individual stories
would have warranted a full video on
their own but gathered up and collected
yeah yeah we got a bit of stuff to cover
here so uh this is not going to be done
in any particular order it's just going
to be the order the notes that I have
for reference are in
okay let's go Yaya Abdul Mateen II has
been cast as Wonder Man For an upcoming
series now I'm familiar with Abdul
Mateen from a couple of things um he was
in the latest Matrix movie I think the
best showcase for him as an actor though
easily has to be his role in Watchmen
um he's really great in that series
that's it is the series not the uh not
the Zack Snyder thing so um I think he's
a great pick to just honestly slot into
just about anything so that's exciting
Wonder Man I do have to admit is a
character I am not super familiar with
but I know a little bit about he is a
superhero he has some Powers but he's
also kind of a celebrity superhero and
not just in like the way that say Tony
Stark or well honestly a lot of the MCU
are kind of celebrity superheroes in
that they are known
um and sort of recognized in the street
it's not just that because the character
is a stunt man and an actor so he's
actually a more traditional celebrity in
addition to having superpowers now this
is going to be for a series on Disney
plus and it's also going to see The
Return of Ben Kingsley as Trevor
Slattery from Iron Man 3 and Xiang Chi
and the legend of the 10 Rings which if
we're dealing with actors in the MCU
like people who have that profession
that's a really easy pull to make so
that makes a ton of sense I'm actually
kind of excited about this the writer
who they got um Andrew guest probably is
the best indicator of the overall tone
of this because most of his work has
been in comedies in one foreign or
another he's done writing for Brooklyn
Nine-Nine as well as Community there's
rumor that Bob Odenkirk is being sought
after to play potentially uh Wonder
man's agent which would be interesting
um there is also some attachment with
Dustin Daniel [ __ ] who is the director
who is executive producing this new
series and may direct some of the
episodes that's not entirely clear yet I
suppose it is worth addressing the
casting in terms of race Wonder Man is
traditionally or at least more
accurately originally a white character
I have not bothered to look up uh what
the rage Merchants uh have decided to
say about this because if they said
anything I already know what they will
have said here's the one major thing
that I will point out aside from the
fact that you know I don't feel that
this is a character where uh the race
being white is intrinsic to the nature
of the character but even beyond that uh
this is not unprecedented because much
like Nick Fury before him Wonder Man was
black in the Ultimate Universe so not
only do we have a president in the
comics for there being a black iteration
of this character it's from the exact
same source that gave us Samuel Jackson
as Nick Fury so I'm gonna go out on a
Lin same most people complaining about
that don't break that up have either
done zero research or are being
deliberately misleading next up we have
some additional casting announcements
for coven of chaos which is what Agatha
the house of Harkness has now been
renamed to now we'd already have the
confirmation of Emma Caufield returning
as Dottie a character that she played in
one division in addition to that we now
have the addition of Aubry Plaza and Joe
Locke Joe Locke I'm not familiar with he
was apparently in Heart Stopper which I
still haven't seen Aubry Plaza makes me
kind of excited there's rumor that she
is going to be playing a villain we
don't know who either of these uh actors
are going to be playing if Aubry plus is
going to be a villain that makes me
really excited because I saw her in
Legion and she was really good at being
off-putting in menacing and villainous
when she went in that mode on that show
so I'm super here for that as for Joe
Locke while I'm not familiar with his
work the rumor at present is that he
might be playing Wiccan which would be
one of the uh children of Wanda so this
theoretically could mean if if true
could mean that we're dealing with some
kind of Multiverse or some kind of time
dilation or magic creating
um a version of what was supposed to be
someone who was never even born in this
particular reality there's a lot of
mechanisms in Marvel at this point to
make that a reality again not confirm
that's who he's going to be but the
rumors are going to run rampant simply
because it hasn't been announced who
they're playing and just the opening
means that lots of rumors and lots of
possibilities are going to be floated
but that one seemed at least feasible
and plausible given the nature of the
show already as a spin-off of One
Division so yeah I thought I'd throw
that out there if there's anything
tempering my excitement for Covenant of
chaos it's that Jack Schaefer is going
to be show running Jack Shafer was the
showrunner on One Division as well well
and Wanda Vision was good and intriguing
until the very end where I really
thought it fell on its face
um I did a whole video on that a while
back but I I suppose there's a chance
that Schaefer has learned
um from the reception to uh one division
especially in regards to some things
that were believed and kind of framed
even in show as being big deals that
ultimately weren't anything and sort of
the frustration fans felt with that so
maybe this will result in a sort of a
better dynamic between uh the creative
work and the fans we'll see that's not
the only thing Schaefer's involved in
Schaefer seems to actually sort of have
staked out the Wanda and vision related
stuff because there's also Vision Quest
that's a working title
um but that is also currently being
headed up by Shaffer at least being
developed
um by Shafer and that is something that
is going to follow so a character that I
need I really need Marvel to come up
with a better name for than white Vision
I know that's not officially what the
character is called but it is the
all-white version of vision that
appeared in one Division and did leave
at the end of that presumably to go on a
journey of self-discovery and there is
now being a series set up to do that
um there's a lot of potentially
interesting stuff there uh it finally my
brain kind of goes so oh so you're gonna
kind of have Vision go through the
Journey that it makes the most sense for
this character to go through
after he's already dead because like one
of the things about vision's
introduction in Age of Ultron was that
he was
kind of fully developed he came about
fully formed now like he would
eventually learn about things like love
and affection you know with Wanda and
had to sort his own feelings and that
but in terms of just general moral
compass sense of humanity broadly
speaking Yeah he already had those
pretty much immediately so taking a much
more
um cold much more uh Android esque
version of vision and have him for the
audience ReDiscover a sense of humanity
and for this particular iteration of
vision find that for the first time it's
kind of interesting in a uh okay so
since you didn't do this at the front
you're just gonna do it now but it
doesn't feel like uh like oh crap we
forgot to do that it feels more like a
well that was an uh that was a
storytelling opportunity we never got to
have but now we've got this other
version of vision so let's have it I do
hope that's something they don't make a
habit of this is something I've
expressed
um reluctance and concerned about before
specifically in regards to the
Multiverse the possibility of bringing
in people either after they've died or
have otherwise become available to to
sort of redo or take a second bite at
the Apple for the character when maybe
they should just be closed out I don't
mind it right now with vision I just
hope that does not start to become
standard now tangentially related to
Vision Quest is
um well related by virtue of being in
the same initial report that first broke
the story which later sort of got
confirmed yes this is being worked on
the second thing has not been confirmed
but again it wasn't a in a report that
did confirm some stuff and that is that
Doctor Doom is not being planned as the
main villain for the Fantastic Four
movie being worked on that doesn't mean
he won't appear at all but he's not
being planned as the main villain uh and
also at this point
um even though at time of recording the
uh Black Panther sequel wakanda forever
is not out for the public to see so I
haven't seen it it has been confirmed by
plenty of people who have that there's
no Dr Doom reference there which some
people have wondered if there was going
to be so I'm actually very okay with
this because Dr Doom is a villain like
as much as he is the iconic villain of
the Fantastic Four he's also somebody
that I think you need to build up a bit
because you have him be the first
villain they deal with it's like like
he's bigger than that it's kind of like
how it made a lot of sense especially
um in hindsight that Batman Begins
didn't deal with the joker right off and
we got to him a little bit later Doctor
Doom is that kind of like let's prove
that this Fantastic Four works and is
gonna stick around before we burn off
one of the best villains in all of
comics
um not that I think they would actually
burn off Doom I expect he will stick
around and they will get a lot of use
out of him or at least they will if
they're smart a couple of other things
real quick a little bit of casting
William Jackson Harper has been
confirmed to be appearing in Ant-Man and
the WASP Quantum Mania he's best known
for playing Chidi in the good place so
I'm happy to see him in anything we have
no idea who he's playing so again
the suspicion immediately kind of goes
kind of big well big in a if you know
the comics way because this is an odd uh
character but the rumor is that he's
going to be voicing or in some way
portraying Modoc who is
a weird dang character
um who has actually kind of been used
already not in the MCU officially but in
fairly recent stuff as he had a a robot
chicken-esque series on Hulu briefly uh
their voice by Pat Oswald now is this uh
the character that Harper's gonna be
playing no idea maybe maybe not but
again the fact that it hasn't been said
who he is playing uh left the door open
for speculation and that's the current
leading fan Theory a couple of other
quick things to wrap everything up armor
Wars is no longer a series now this is
going to Star uh war machine so don
cheadle's character of roadie that was
going to be a Disney plus series it's
now going to be a film
um regardless of the shape that it takes
I actually am kind of excited about this
Roadie so far in the MCU has been very
much
defined by being kind of a sidekick kind
of a second banana you know he was
around because he was Tony's friend and
even in later films it very much was
something that felt like he was a
psychic he was there because Tony was
there but Tony's now gone so he actually
has a chance to chart his own path and
I'll be very interested to see how that
pans out and I'm actually the more I
think about it kind of glad it's going
to be a movie because I like the idea of
taking this character who's been around
for a while and elevating him to give
him a big Premiere like hey
this guy who's just kind of been there
and he's been you know a good character
an enjoyable character but he's kind of
been second fiddle let's show you how
awesome he can be on the biggest canvas
we can make we can provide for him which
is a film as opposed to a series so
I am kind of interested in that it it
makes me think that whatever they were
planning to do was going to be a fairly
serial serialized single story a bit
like what uh Falcon and the Winter
Soldier was but that in developing it
maybe they realized you know actually we
could do this as six nearly hour-long
episodes or we could cut some of the
subplots and get a really good movie out
of the main plot that we're doing now I
don't know that's what happened but
that's gonna kind of be my assumption
until I find out otherwise uh somewhat
also related to that Iron Heart the
Disney plus series two star Riri
Williams who is a character being
introduced in uh wakanda forever so I
don't have an opinion on the
characterized presented in the MCU yet I
haven't seen her and I'm not super
familiar with her from the comics other
than you know the fact that she exists
um but her Series has wrapped filming so
that is moving forward uh steadily and
seems to be on schedule which is always
a good thing the Disney Plus shows for
the most part have been pretty good
about that we haven't heard too much
about budget or shooting schedule
overruns uh as far as these things go if
they're happening at all they are
keeping on top of it pretty decently and
the last thing is now this is a pretty
quick offhanded thing but the Russo
brothers who had started directing MCU
films with the second Captain America
movie basically said yeah we're not
going to do another Marvel movie this
decade now that does leave open the
possibility that may maybe they could
get involved further down the line but
now we're talking like 2030 and they
really seem to give the impression like
look we had our time at the wheel we put
our stamp on it let us do other things
right now which you know fair enough uh
they did really kind of leave their Mark
for what they helmed and you know doing
not only several Captain America's uh
but doing like one of the big ones with
Civil War and then doing uh infinity war
and end game
like that's a pretty solid Legacy within
this franchise and that's also like a
good point to walk away and take a break
if you're gonna stop at some point end
game's a good point to stop so the thing
is I'm not sure I'm like super
disappointed by this notion I think the
russos did really great work but part of
the reason they did great work was
because of the nature of the MCU and
their own background as TV directors
being that they're used to coming in
basically just working with actors who
already know how these characters
function for the most part and they're
just putting them into something that is
going to best service all these
characters in the best story that they
can as opposed to being like core
creative Visionaries for the thing as a
whole that's not to say they didn't put
their own stamp on it they did but they
don't have a particularly unique feel to
their work and that doesn't make it bad
I really enjoyed the films that they
directed but they don't feel uniquely
touched by a specific directorial intent
so unless the MCU as a whole really
feels like it needs a really strong
Steady Hand because it's gone off the
rails which while I haven't loved phase
four I'm not prepared to say that it's
at that kind of point I don't think that
someone like the russos really is
required right now and I'd be more
interested with seeing stuff that is
more just geared towards having unique
or interesting directors do something
with it as much as I ultimately am very
much disappointed with uh Doctor Strange
of the Multiverse of Madness Sam Remy's
fingerprints are all over that and that
is the kind of directorial choices that
I want to see more of with Marvel and so
that should wrap pretty much everything
up what are your thoughts about any of
this whatever they are drop something
out in the comments let's talk about it
what are you excited for what did I miss
there's been a lot if you want to
support what I do patreon is the best
way to do that there's also YouTube
memberships you can follow me on Twitch
there's a bunch of stuff you can do
links in the description for or all
sorts of stuff but don't worry too much
about it what I really want you to do is
remember that you are beautiful
you're valid and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council is adjourned
[Music]
end credits that means I need to shout
out my top Patron supporters Robin Moore
zupin but fulla to rock the thing that
goes doing in the anime Oliver B Linda
Walters emu Delhi leotha Boyd toy lowly
Becky Sparks bernabe likes the poodle
Zach Tracy scrabot angry Casper Adam RDL
Taylor Shay legourlay Brendan Larose and
TT
thank you so much for your support you
can get your name in the credits too by
checking out the rewards on the patreon
you only try deep my earring once this
time that's much better
[Music]